[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition des entretiens de france 24 et
nous allons recevoir notre aujourd'hui
l'oms fait étrangère d'un des voisins
immédiats de l'ukraine membre de l'otan
et de l'union européenne depuis 2004
merci d'être avec nous s'il m'avoir
invité je voudrais commencer à vous
parlons de la sécu ce militaire en
ukraine et il ya un convoi de 40km de
véhicules militaires qui vont vers sur
kiev qu'est ce que vous pensez que
prévoit vladimir poutine
malheureusement la situation sécuritaire
en ukraine sa grâce
il semble que le président russe
continue de l'agression contre l'état
souverain et indépendant d'ukraine qui
est très malheureux
[Musique]
nous voyons que ça se produit malgré le
cycle de consultations qui a eu lieu
hier entre les diplomates s'étreignant
et russe
est effectivement très regrettable je
pense que les négociations peuvent
aboutir si elle se déroule sous un feu
nourri
de citations de la situation est donc
effectivement très difficile et j'espère
que les appels de la communauté
internationale seront entendus par le
président poutine
a mis son accent nucléaire en état d'
alerte maximum est ce que c'est une
menace réelle ou simplement d
intimidation
je pense qu'il est extrêmement
irresponsable de menacer d'utiliser des
armes nucléaires
je ne pense pas qu'au xxième siècle
puis si on faire de telles menaces
je ne suis pas personnellement convaincu
que cela serait suivi d'une utilisation
effective et l'armé nucléaire mais la
menace de les utiliser est tout à fait
inacceptable
elle a été condamnée comme tel par la
communauté internationale
nous l'avons également condamné gelé
personnellement condamné lors de la
réunion du conseil des affaires
étrangères de l'union européenne le 27
février à bruxelles et tous mes
homologues ont fait de même le président
ukrainien et lens qui a demandé à
l'occident de mettre en place une au fly
zone sur l'ukraine qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
je pense que la position déjà exprimée
par l'otan était très clair
il a également été exprimées par
d'autres alliés de l'otan à agir de la
sorte signifierait que l'otan serait
directement impliqué dans ce conflit
militaire de ce qu'un autre
c'est impossible puisque l'ukraine n'est
pas membre de l'alliance qui
signifierait que l'otan serait
directement impliqué dans cette
confrontation militaire
malheureusement cette demande il ne peut
pas recevoir une réponse positive de la
part de l'otan
et des troupes et du matériel autant
supplémentaires vont être déployés en
roumanie au cours des jours à venir la
roumanie plus sûrs ou plus vulnérables
des attaques et évidemment on peut
réfléchir à ce qui va se passer la
situation qui se construit à l'est de
l'europe est ce que ça peut être perçu
comme une provocation
ne peut pas être considérée comme une
provocation ou une mesure d' escalade à
ce que nous avons fait sur le flanc
oriental depuis 2014 après l'occupation
illégale de la crimée était une réponse
une réaction d'autodéfense pour
construire là dissuasion et la posture
de défense de l'otan sur le flanc
oriental en raison justement des actions
ordonnées par la russie si nous
comparons la taille des forces en
présences environ quinze mille soldats
de l'otan sur le flanc ailleurs
confiante aller plus de cent cinquante
mille militaires russes dans le bassin
de la mer noire
je pense qu'il est tout à fait clair est
ce que l'otan fait sur le flanc oriental
n'est pas du tout une provocation contre
la russie mais plutôt une réponse
légitime de l'alliance pour la sécurité
des alliés sur le flanc oriental
l'otan consolide sa position sur le
flanc oriental depuis un certain temps
et nous le demandons mais cette crise a
accéléré ce processus nous continuons à
demander davantage de trous et
d'équipements sur le territoire de la
roumanie dans la partie sud du flanc
oriental qui est la plus exposée la
roumanie à la plus grande frontière
terrestre avec l'ukraine 2 640 km de
frontière avec l'ukraine
également la crimée à environ 300 km de
la côte où mène
le passé au nord ouest de la mer noire
et je pense qu'il est très légitime
d'avoir davantage de troupes de l'otan
en roumanie des soldats américains sont
déjà arrivés les militaires français
arrivent ces jours-ci d'autres radiées
comme la belgique vont déployer des
forces en roumanie et je pense qu'il est
très important de voir que la solidarité
des alliés fonctionne
nous sommes heureux d'accueillir
davantage d'alliés en roumanie dans la
partie sud du flanc oriental sur la mer
noire nous avons besoin de cette
dissuasion de cette défense face à ce
que fait la russie dans notre voisinage
direct
on entend des rapports de personnes sur
le terrain et d'un certain nombre de
pays qui sont directement à la limite
que ce soit la humane
la slovaquie et d'autre on expriment des
craintes que ça puisse déborder vers
leur pays est ce que vous pensez c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait se produire
nous considérons que la roumanie
citoyens roumains n'ont aucune raison
d'avoir peur qu'un nous sommes couverts
par les garanties de sécurité inscrite à
l'article 5 du traité de l'atlantique
nord ce collectif garantie par l'otan et
par les forces alliées et à toute
épreuve je pense que les débordements ne
toucheront pas les pays de l'otan en
aucun cas
en effet la situation sécuritaire dans
son ensemble se détériore c'est pourquoi
comme nous l'avons vu précédemment la
consolidation du flanc oriental est en
cours et les mesures prises par l'otan
ne sont rien d'autre qu'une réponse à
l'attitude agressive de la russie encore
une fois
à l'intérieur de l'ukraine ont entendu
parler de part
et d'autre sur l'utilisation de bombes à
fragmentation le fait que les civils
soient visés par les forces russes est
ce que vous pensez que
ceci pourrait prouver qu'il y avait des
crimes de guerre commis par la russie
ne pouvons pas dire que cela se produit
car nous n'avons pas dieu sur le terrain
directement à la tuerie mais si c'est le
cas c'est bien sûr tout à fait contraire
au droit international aux lois
régissant la guerre et au droit
humanitaire international
pourquoi la cpi à la haye a commencé
aujourd'hui à examiner la possibilité
d'ouvrir une enquête sur d'éventuels
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité pendant le conflit en ukraine
je pense qu'une telle enquête est tout à
fait légitime
sur les autres questions des droits de
l'homme on s'est beaucoup préoccuper de
la question des réfugiés qui quittent l
ukraine
beaucoup sont en train de passer par la
roumanie en tout les nations unies
parlent de 660 mille personnes qui ont
quitté l'ukraine dans diverses
directions est ce que vous savez combien
d'entre eux sont en roumanie où passent
par la roumanie oui évidemment nous le
savons puisque nous suivons la situation
de très près et nous avons décidé de
faciliter l'entrée sur le territoire
roumain de tous les citoyens ukrainiens
qui ont besoin de protection
du 10 février jusqu'à hier plus de 130
mille citoyens ukrainiens sont arrivés
sur le territoire roumain
près de quarante mille d'entre eux sont
restés en roumanie
calculez le nombre d'entrées et de
sorties du territoire vers d'autres pays
de mieux également lire les sorties et
nous avons décidé de prendre soin de ces
personnes qui ont un grand besoin de
protection ce sont surtout des mères des
enfants qui arrivent ensemble avec la
société civile avec un grand nombre d
ong et avec également des roumains nous
tentons de foi ni à une forme des deux
refuges d'alimentation
fournissons des médicaments tout ce dont
ils ont besoin pour se sentir en
sécurité puisque la roumanie est un pays
sûr
mentionné de faciliter l'arrivée des
citoyens craignent un mais je voudrais
vous poser la question des citoyens
d'autres pays qui ont été résident en
ukraine et sans passer par l'ukraine
est-ce qu'il figure parmi les gens que
la roumanie accueil
café nous avons facilité l'entrée en
roumanie des citoyens d'autres pays une
partenaire il ya de nombreux citoyens de
pays tiers qu'il s'agisse de pays
européens où des ressortissants de pays
de jeu votants ou d'autres pays du monde
qui ont demandé une autre tuile dont
fourni notre api devant faciliter leur
entrée sur le territoire humain et leur
évacuation vers leur pays d'origine nous
avons également faciliter un grand
nombre
d'entrées de personnel des missions
diplomatiques en roumanie pour qu'ils
puissent ensuite rentrer chez eux
la roumanie est un pays ouvert et qui
est tout à fait disposé à fournir son
assistance à tous ceux qui en ont besoin
au citoyen ukrainienne et il ya deux
mondes d'autres pays qui sont dans une
situation de détresse dans ce pays et
qui souhaitent le quitter de manière
sûre
le jour où le président zelensky a lancé
un appel chargée d'émotion au parlement
à la commission au conseil de l'union
européenne pour qu'ils soutiennent
l'ukraine et vivre la voix dans son
parcours à l'accession un certain nombre
de pays y compris votre voisin la
bulgarie ont proposé de donner
immédiatement le statut de candidat et
d'ouvrir les négociations
est-ce que la roumanie soutient cela
oui évidemment
non seulement à l'occasion de cette
crise mais par le passé également à la
roumanie a déjà soutenu le projet
européen de l'ukraine cela fait
longtemps que nous le soutenons
la roumanie était le premier états
membres à ratifier l'accord
d'association et l'accord de libre
échange entre l'ukraine et l'union
européenne il ya de nombreuses années il
soutenons donc le projet européen de
l'ukraine mais également celui de la
république de moldavie et celui de la
géorgie puisque nous considérons que la
place de ces pays et dans l'union
européenne donc réaffirmé le projet
européen de ces pays est une priorité
pour la roumanie
notre président on l'avait déjà souligné
de manière très ferme et j'avais
également fait de même et nous
fournissons
un appui dans ce sens évidemment
le projet européen doit être mérité par
ces pays mais le processus d'adhésion
est long
il nécessite beaucoup de temps mais nous
sommes clairement résolus à les aider
dans ce processus
je vous remercie de
match merci à vous merci d'avoir regardé
cette émission et nouveau entreprendre
la prochaine fois
[Musique]